Iconic!
I love to know the life of the stuff I'm going to eat
before it shows up on my plate.
That's why I'm in Canada's
Maritime Provinces and Quebec
during the season of bounty.
To connect with the land and rich history
through people and food.
Good morning!
Hi, I’m Matthieu.
It's a region famous for its Gaelic,
Mi'kmaq and Acadian cultures.
And a bounty of heritage farm animals.
They are turning this place that
used to be a monoculture of corn
into a place of biodiversity,
bringing tons of animals and trying
to feed the ground and create
this virtuous cycle
that will bring more life.
The skin is so thin...
It's like caviar.
The idea is that with so much
biodiversity that we have going on,
it'll naturally take care of itself.
With the longest coastline in the world,
Canada's communities in Nova Scotia
and New Brunswick are dependent
on lobster fishing, which makes up about
half of their fisheries industry.
Making it a crucial source of revenue
and cultural pride.
Cuz down here in Cap Pelé, we got the best
tasting lobster in the world.
Is that so?
Yep.
There’s 250 traps. We lift up all the traps every day.
Put fresh bait. Put that back in the water.
So you need to measure every lobster
to make sure it's a legal one.
Down here it’s 79 millimeters and up.
The females with eggs
you have to throw them back.
A good lobster fisherman?
Yeah, what makes a good lobster fisherman?
You need to have it right here...
You need to have love.
You need to be passionate
about what you do.
And you need to go out
every day and do your best.
I always love stories that deal
with people that are on the edge
of fitting in fully but also very proud
of where they are standing.
Visiting the ancestral homelands
of the Mi’kmaq people
along the Miramichi River
is an opportunity to experience
the growing indigenous tourism industry
and connect with the land and history
of the region through the people
who have called it home for centuries.
We got really, really high water
today.
Yep.
Because of all the rain?
Yeah.
Throw it out. Let it fall.
Let it fall?
And then let it drift.
You take your thumb and your hand
and you're just going to
bring the rod up to here.
And then wait a split
second and then throw it out.
It's good?
Yeah. It's your first cast.
Okay, excellent!
And then your heart starts pounding.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
This is wild mint
and we use it as medicine.
Smell that? Isn't that beautiful?
These are tea berries
and they're very bitter.
A little bit, yeah, towards the end.
We want to have good food.
We want to have clean water, clean air.
Pass things on to our kids.
And for a long time, our culture
was denied that opportunity.
We can finally stand up for ourselves
and we can be proud of who we are.
Proud of just living and surviving as Mi’kmaq
people here on the East Coast of Canada.
Stay there.
Mama mia, look at these beauties!
How are the mustard pickles?
Very good.
Legend has it
that the Hopewell rocks
formed from the pots
Mi’kmaq people once used
to feast and celebrate with.
Walking on the seafloor
of the Bay of Fundy, due to its famous
extreme variability in tides, it's
easy to feel the history
and significance of this land.
A quick flight and we are in Quebec.
Taking its name from the
famous Mont Royal Park
which overlooks the city, Montréal
is one of the greenest cities in the world
for its sustainability
and its many green spaces.
On top of the city's convention center
sits an unexpected farm.
Montréal is really the world
capital of urban agriculture.
There’s almost 60 urban farms, it’s
double the amount of similar cities.
I want to transform the city.
Farm on the rooftop will have an impact
for biodiversity in downtown.
Chard.
Rainbow chard.
Yeah.
Tomatoes.
Oh, my God.
When I'm doing a dish,
I'm looking at like,
what's the season vegetables.
The restaurants in Montréal, they want to
work with farms to stay local.
You're going to get a live reaction here.
Are you afraid, are you scared?
Yes, I'm stressed.
It's great that she's
focusing on seasonality in the dishes.
Meeting people
and having meaningful encounters
is something that really stays with me.
Canadians are defined as being, quote
unquote, nice.
I think they have much
more character than that.
There is a sense of contemplation
and excitement to see that you can nurture
your soul, nurture yourself,
nurture other people,
and a love for their environment
that I really enjoyed.